un message fort non seulement pour le
pour l'humanité
[Musique]
de cette intervention qui était alors
petite intervention de une poignée de
personnes alors celle-là ça va c'est la
globalement d'autres après voilà c'est
la globalement c'est des militants
d'extrême gauche qui l'interpellent qui
remettent en question sa politique où
est la démocratie française ils font
allusion à ce qu'ils soient
et donc là c'est une interruption et je
trouve qu'il réagit plutôt pas mal parce
que à posteriori il dit d'ailleurs on
peut en débattre etc donc là c'est assez
soft c'était à La Haye pour le moment
c'est assez soft il y a pas de
débordement majeur après on peut se
demander suite pourquoi ils ont été là
c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas un truc
politique
mais d'accord mais c'est pas là c'est
pas un parti qui les a envoyés non non
non
c'est pas mes copains
dans le dans l'ordre et le calme un
échange des bottes pratique on va dire
celui qui suit les beaucoup oui regardez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà
bon alors on n'a pas trop vu visiblement
alors j'aurais tendance à dire que c'est
le service de sécurité qui fait son
travail de sécurité je pose une question
ce qu'on a vu précédemment était
intervenu aussi mais là il y a double
services de sécurité les services
néerlandais et aussi le groupement de
sécurité de la présence de la République
la sécurité du président parce que
l'homme court vers lui donc là il y a
pas le même côté je dirais débat
politique il y a le côté potentiel
agression alors après quand il s'en va
il chante l'hymne des gilets jaunes il
se voit il retrouve
se retrouve un peu de politique mais au
départ ils ont eu vraiment peur d'une
agression est-ce que le président
pour l'instant il n'a pas été au match
en tout cas il évite les JO ça va moi je
pense que c'est deux images là elles
sont à l'image de ce que va être la fin
de son quinquennat et à l'étranger comme
en France puisqu'il a pas osé aller il a
pas plu
il a du boulot
et bien sûr
à Béatrice
alors je voudrais juste justement
clarifier on peut avoir des désaccords
politiques avec les gens et ne pas
détester la personne mais combattre des
idées sans détester la personne je
trouve la deuxième image assez violente
en fait
effectivement les services de sécurité
doivent protéger les personnalités
politiques c'est tout à fait normal mais
en ce moment on voit quand même des
réactions assez violentes
une personne qui part qui avance en
courant vers un président de quel que
soit la République si les mecs le
placent pas au soleil
en pense est-ce que c'est normal ce
qu'ils ont fait oui bien sûr
[Musique]
je n'ai pas vu courir
parce qu'il est quand même proche des
présidents si la sécurité parce que là
regardez le Président il est on va dire
à 5,6 mètres
à nous expliquer mais il y a des
distances quand même à respecter
on voit des gens qui sont pas très loin
donc il suffit
et fonce et là il intercepte il aurait
pu faire tirer dessus pour le pour le
stopper alors toujours dans le ballon
c'est vrai qu'en ce moment c'est un peu
compliqué pour le Président on peut pas
se mentir il y a une déclaration qui
n'est pas passée mais alors pas du tout
c'est sa déclaration concernant Taïwan à
la Chine là Trump toujours dans la
classe de Donald Trump avec lui tout
passe tout l'as sous la classe regardez
on a un problème vous vous avez ce monde
de fou qui explose de partout et les
États-Unis n'ont absolument pas leur mot
à dire Macron qui est un ami est avec la
Chine en train de lui lécher le cul
est un ami heureusement que c'est un ami
c'est vrai que il va quand même Donald
Trump
il fait du Donald Trump mais en même
temps dans la presse étrangère par
exemple en Allemagne a-t-il perdu la
tête
dit qu'il a sapé les efforts des
Américains enfin c'est c'est quand même
il exprime d'une façon évidemment à la
façon de Donald Trump puisque pense
beaucoup de gens il a eu quelques
soutien quand même en Europe non très
peu Italie je crois l'Espagne me semble
aussi l'Allemagne non en fait on lui
reproche d'avoir dit que
d'être sous le sous le saut de
l'Amérique
merci
c'est le fameux non alignement quoi
il a dit ça c'est la Chine fait des
manœuvres dans cerclement de Taïwan qui
veulent reconquérir qui veulent remettre
dans le girond de la Chine
n'intervient pas c'est parce qu'elle se
sont menacées en cas d'intervention par
les États-Unis et peut-être par ses
alliés l'Europe et la Macron dit que la
France n'a pas vocation à suivre
forcément les États-Unis sous-entendu un
message au président chinois si vous
attaquez Taïwan les États-Unis m'ont
répliqué mais nous l'Europe on fera rien
donc c'est pour ça que ça ça cause un
gros problème pour la solidarité de
l'auto
c'est une erreur mais bien sûr quand il
menace d'intervention aussi rapide aussi
forte que aussi forte que la Chine parce
que la Chine rigole pas les attaques ils
ont certes l'île pour l'instant s'ils
attaquent il faut que j'ai payé alliés
ce sont ce sont tous
Jean-Michel parce que au Quentin on a
pas à suivre aveuglément
du général de Gaulle aussi c'est
indépendant française par rapport aux
États-Unis qui sinon vont nous bouffer
de manière donc mais non mais c'est pas
ça mais je trouve qu'il y a une manière
de dire on est indépendant on a notre
propre voix européenne a créé qui est
intéressant tu peux le dire forcément
en Europe il parle un peu au nom de
l'Europe quoi
je me suis concerné avec mes homologues
européens donc c'est pas seulement de la
France
tu dis pas ça ou au moins il y a une
menace imminente mais surtout que
l'Europe n'était pas d'accord
il a pas été suivi d'ailleurs par le par
les pays européens en plus il a pas
extrêmement soutenu donc on parle au nom
de l'Europe qui soutient pas
on peut mettre savoir ce qui va se
passer dans le vide parce que là la loi
va être vraisemblablement adoptée en
tout cas l'idée à défaut d'être adopté